one thing one thing about the jojo event
though that i i wish that
i wish that anime did have more of these
kinds of events because i would say like
one thing that always makes me jealous
as an anime fan
from watching you know the gaming
community is that having this
live event where they have like a load
of things announced at once right
like i've always been you want an e3 of
anime i kind of do
because i would love the presentations
like honestly
check this out honestly half the fun of
e3 it's just feeling like it's it's just
like what
feeling like you're part of a community
and just watching it and just reacting
to it right
because like because like to me like the
closest thing anime has is like the
anime awards right but we don't really
have any
what just the mental image
guys i'm proud to announce incest the
anime
me and me at the team but incest anime
have worked really hard
this time this time in 8k
most anime i i do not want to know the
thought process
as to why this came to be and i do not
want to do do you want do you want to
want some 50 year old men telling me
why he thinks this 12 year old girl
should [ __ ] this 20 year old man
i don't want that i don't want to see a
presentation of that that is the last
thing i want
last time we heard that the plot got in
the way of the incest so we decided to
just go to bang bros
guys we hear you you want another easter
egg i just imagine
like check this out the [ __ ] pornhub
[ __ ] thing please
[Music]
no but like do you care about most of
the games that get announced that are
like
you know you wait for that one jojo part
six announcement yeah you wait for
i don't know what what else i just think
that we should get more live events
to announce anime just for the hype
factor like it makes sense no no that's
that's what i miss i i want
i i like the hype factor in um that the
gaming community have you know it's i i
feel like
it's it adds to this community aspect
and it adds to the fun
yeah yeah i mean japan kind of has that
already yeah yeah on nikon
they have this event called suzukimi
which i did
the english version of at ax last time
right but um yeah it's it's literally
like a live event where they get a bunch
of like voice actors and hosts to
announce the next season of anime maybe
they should subtitle this
maybe you could subtitle it like imagine
how hype it would be when
like you hear like a chainsaw man
adaptation yeah just seeing it on
twitter right you have this event
where you're like oh it's [ __ ] you
know it's it's the next thing he's a
trailer yeah yeah
where you're like oh is this chainsaw
man is this like jujutsu kaisen before
though he's got animated you know like
there's this they just play like scenes
of the anime yeah
like there are some manga series i know
people are waiting for like
imagine like one day vagabond gets
announced or some [ __ ] like that i would
lose my [ __ ] yeah you know and i i you
know i think it would be cool if anime
had this kind of event where
we just announced a bunch of new anime
getting getting adapted why
why we should do that
honestly like we're saying this idea i'm
just like no one's going to do it
anime companies reach out to you yeah
please yeah we'll do it
it's just it just feels hard to be an
anime fan you know [ __ ] we just
we spend we spend a [ __ ] ton of money we
get we get beat down on you know [ __ ]
man it's hard
you're not japanese